d'accord il faudra compter absolument
n'importe quoi bien sûr mais pourquoi il
ya dire qu'on ait marqué vous avez une
sortir l'étoile jaune de te raconter
n'importe quoi bon vous raconter
n'importe quoi
la première la première chose que je
trouve inacceptables dans l'argument du
docteur c'est que on ne peut pas
utiliser le fait d'un exemple d'un
hôpital italien où on aurait choisi
entre deux et c'est possible dans la
mesure où je pourrai si on jouait à la
bataille est ce que vous étiez de
m'emmener dans un jeu de roy trêve
bataille machin picard au coeur qui me
semble totalement infantile et même
enfantin c'est que je pourrais vous
opposer ce que je ne vais pas faire
encore que le nombre d'enfants qui se
sont suicidés cette année car ça vous le
prenez jamais en compte six gendarmes et
non mais vous venez comme vous êtes en
béarn et par là et je viens aussi aux
enfants et que que vous soyez
cyniquement crispé sur cette maladie
alors que les maladies adjacentes
celles qui ont fait des ravages
psychologiques psychiatriques chez des
êtres à peu près sain le fait que des
enfants de 15 ans de 12 ans de 7 ans se
tranche la gorge se serre avec un lacet
la gorge pour quitter cette terre parce
qu'ils ne sont pas sortis depuis un an
le fait qu'on nous empêche de faire du
sport depuis un an
le fait qu'on sache que les mares que ne
servent à rien à l'extérieur qu'on sache
et vous vous nous avez quoi une sorte de
panique mortifère où il faudrait rester
sous cloche parce que des gens comme
vous ont considéré qu'elle est au moins
deux ans on avait la vie devant là je ne
veux plus en tant que ce discours c'est
irresponsable un job dit docteur valroc
pas avoir entendu les cas sévères comme
moi j'ai déjà très bien j'en dis aux
verts dans les vallons 80 balais lewis
encore ils ont la vie devant max ans et
je trouve ça très bien mis l'accent
c'est très bien mais vous voulez
entendre au futur et gesvres pour aller
regarder les encore fille ou qu'on a été
les premiers jeux sur l'état mental des
malheureux
et qu'on a dit malheureusement
contrairement ça comme sur le poser les
lecteurs contrairement à ce que
proposait le raison de verre vous avez
raison de soulever le couvercle parce
qu'ils avaient pris la dimension du
mental des français qui étaient
désastreux alors allez pas dire les
villages de la générale et ravale cette
génération de médecins l'enfant gâté qui
ont oublié quand ils ont commencé leurs
études de médecine de faire un peu de
philosophie de réfléchir ça donne en
fait que j'appelle moi des beaufs de la
médecine
ce sont des gens saison insulté par ce
mec ça suffit mais là ça suffit ça fait
deux fois qu'on a chuté tout cela
produits de la médecine et ça va bien
moi voir mon pote je suis mal si côtier
p2c alors bof de la médecine etc dira je
veux dire c'est vrai que j'ai pas le
temps que tu aurais philosophie à la
retraite alors c'est bon le passé que
non mais ça va bien et j'ai connu et je
connais la période heureusement j'ai
moins en fac de médecine
il y avait du genre il devait faire
médecine en étant littéraire donc c'est
bon qu'il arrête de nous insulter ce
type
franchement là les médias seront bien à
ce moment vous un intérêt à voleter vous
avez pas le nom pour celui ci vous
avouerez 18 jours se suicider vous en
fichez vous êtes
ici je suis là c'est à dire la vérité je
parlais mort à des morts on oppose par
un mode oui la gym a donné l'exemple
italien qui choisissent en train un
homme de 55 ans à celle terrain dans ce
genre de débats cet argument là et nulle
il est là pour faire faire l'adversaire
c'est cette fois des monologues